oh sorry did I actually hit you in the
ball sack yes you do I'm sorry good yes
again be something I can put in their
profession I'll care what the hell
happens what do the stern the Jackass
the nose
it's a giant robotic bear it's gonna
hurt
Oh
yeah fuck
something broke up I'm all broke this is
what we did to teddy beauty's eye that's
a good childhood you're crazy
now like it oh oh my god oh my god this
is sick this is all your kids used to
play with this can play with yeah oh my
god it's like that video with that guy
who takes off his nose yeah except a
caterpillar see it'll be over I am going
to rip off Teddy's head here we go oh my
god that's really hard to rip off oh
that let's twist look at Oh
that's just twisted that's in say that's
literally twisted broken a snake maybe I
should cut it okay this is really mad
Sheldon
oh wow with the wires it's like organs
this one decapitated teddy Wow
I can see it right before I die yeah
this is what I'm going to help
shut up